you think Donald Trump would have gotten
the memo by now to cool it on the
immigrant bashing especially when it
comes to Latinos because guess what
they're the fastest-growing group of
voters in the country this year 8
million more Latinos will be eligible to
vote than in 2008
Joaquin and Catalina Escovedo are two
such new voters they've been living here
in Houston for 36 years and this year
they finally took the plunge to become
citizens I recorded p.m. for a guru in
Los Angeles in person Trudel el
pensamiento when approving Gigandet
agendas we are done I work in Miramar
click on Maria Enomoto Sione's they're
part of a blitz of permanent residents
who are naturalizing in the final months
of 2015
applications for citizenship were up
five percent over the last presidential
election year and since then 1.2 million
people have become citizens why now well
there's one possibility como que si
president a similar hacer las cosas bien
con la gente well de Rohan like a gun in
a hole for que pasa gana el me more I
knows no stopper alla turca CACREP on it
your way or whatever Clinton Pierre de
Oh Rodney
yes Cavazos became citizens with the
help of neighborhood centers a community
organization in Houston we have
candidates will have so openly and
continuously talking about immigration
that's really hearing our community
especially the Latino community hearing
them for okay we're scared if this
candidate becomes the president we don't
know what will happen to immigration law
we won't know what will happen to our
brothers and sisters in a normal year
the organization helps about 600 people
become citizens but this year it's
looking more like a thousand to 1500 and
it's a lot of work the process requires
civic lessons practicing English and
prepping for a final citizenship exam
que para un tiss ma la pregunta vamos a
poner Couture administrivia became a
presenter thousand English George
Washington Airport oh no no not all I
can tell at en the schemas take a
containing has Trasolini son of Trezza
Colonia
that I say colonial-era yo Melvina the
excavators are part of a growing
population of Latinos in Houston and
though the city is one of the most
diverse in the country Vasquez says you
wouldn't know it by looking at who's
voting we are to seeing this region
become a majority in people of color and
yet we still don't represent that in the
voting for the rest of the country will
start to look like what Houston looks
like right now
and so our responsibility for Joaquin
and his wife and others like him is to
ensure that we are a welcoming city so
that they can contribute no Muslim Dimas
contentos yeah gusto porque ahora
famously events before the movie will
start developing on order parameter set
we acquired up and the congressmen are
layers and ties
you